I've ordered two different Chili's
restaurants and one time in a sushi
place out here in Los Angeles
I saw flea from the Red Hot Chili
Peppers so yes I'm allowed to wear this
shirt hello my name is grace Helbig and
i trihard i don't know what's happening
here but somehow choices were made
recently I did a video with Clearasil
telling you about one of my embarrassing
pimple stories you can quite a few it
was really fun thanks Jay telling that
story and I actually take the wind out
of the sails of the vote of
embarrassment that that story was
traveling on for me and I started
thinking about how we all have
embarrassing moments all the time
constantly forever I've had a lot of
embarrassed right now the fix happening
with this hair and I've developed a
Brooke system of handling embarrassing
moments and I thought I'd share that
with you today and I thought it would be
helpful to help you remember how to
handle embarrassing moments by creating
an acronym for the steps and the acronym
spells out so let's get into it first
step comp it is imperative that you try
to stay as calm as possible after the
embarrassing moment has happened haha TV
show that was unexpected
the embarrassing moment is like the
discovery of a dinosaur if you are
screaming and freaking out that dinosaur
is going to eat you but if you're calm
the dinosaur probably won't eat you for
like a good 2/3 of the movie leave if
the situation allows you to physically
exit get out of there ASAP before
anything else can happen if you can't
physically try to check out mentally
think about that's the one evaluate
after the situation take a second to
truly look back on what actually
happened where is the actual damage who
saw what happened and how can you
possibly find some positive in the
situation when embarrassing situation
happens for me my brain literally goes
tell me everything you can't see through
it Silverlight
my book no oh wow ask a friend would
actually happen I know for myself when I
do something embarrassing and I look
back on it I don't remember it as it was
really rationalized think about it with
as clear your mind as you can will this
actually affect your future most likely
no acknowledge with your newfound sense
of rationale it's time to acknowledge
that this is just a passing fleeting
moment of time like what t-swift can't
do after a breakup it's time for you to
move on - I'm just kidding that was an
easy joke that was for my society and
not my actual
opinions please just put me in your
entourage that's never going to happen
you try to spoil an embarrassing moment
is an emotional roller coaster for you
you've been through a lot time to treat
yourself get yourself something nice you
earned it
very sharp there is an online shopping
cart waiting for you and now if you're
still not over it
try to imagine worse scenarios Civic
Northwest you know that should know
leverage if all else fails hopefully
someone recorded the embarrassing moment
you can leverage it into a viral video
that's forthe beginning your newfound
life as a successful digital personality
good luck does Michelle Fonz you're in
need a new catchphrase there you go
there's my process for handling an
embarrassing moment if you can't
remember the steps just remember
Clearasil talk about organic brand
integration honestly I think this is a
pretty decent way to try and handle an
embarrassing moment it goes hand-in-hand
with the pebble story which if you
haven't seen click here to go watch it
just remember that it's not gonna last
forever and life will move forward it's
a circle life like that potentially
mentally unstable genderless monkey from
The Lion King tells us I learned a lot
from the monkey I don't know Oh